[Music]
the line between imagination and reality
has long been the realm of cinematic and
literary
exploration but now thanks to research
published in 2023 scientists are gaining
new insights into one of the most
mysterious transitions in human
consciousness the shift from
reality-based perception to internal
imaginative brain States
imagination really allows you to come up
with what things would be like in
alternative realities which is something
that's really powerful it can help you
plan things you can imagine okay if I'm
going to have this dinner what what is
it going to taste like is that something
I like okay well then let me go and make
that for dinner for example so it allows
you to really like plan your future it's
just interesting to know how your brain
distinguishes internally generated
content from stuff that is out there in
the world but scientists have long
struggled to understand the puzzling
Neuroscience behind our ability to
distinguish between perception and
Imagination since both use many of the
same parts of the
brain in 1910 psychologist Mary perky
was trying to develop a scientific
definition of imagination so she devised
an experiment that produced a surprising
result test subjects were asked to stare
at a blank wall and imagine a certain
fruit meanwhile behind the scenes perky
projected a very faint image of the
fruit on the wall when asked if they saw
anything real the particip ipants were
sure they hadn't although they commented
on how Vivid the image they were
imagining seemed perky concluded that
when our perception of something matches
what we're imagining we will assume
we've imagined it this would eventually
come to be known as the perky effect
since then there's been a handful of
studies that try to replicate it but
results were very mixed but now in the
last decades kind of with the
advancement of neuroimaging we've shown
time and time again that when we imagine
something many of the same brain uh
processes be become involed as when we
would actually see that same thing so
Dyer and her team designed an updated
version of Perky's experiment the setup
was similar but to better control for
the variability in imagined objects the
researchers asked participants to
imagine something more specific diagonal
lines participants stared at a static
screen and were asked to imagine the
lines just as in Perky's experiment
faint images would appear and disappear
what we found was actually kind of
surprising because we did did not find a
perky effect instead in results
published in 2023 a more nuanced picture
emerged when the researchers asked
participants if the lines they saw were
real or imagined the responses varied
when they were shown faint images of the
lines participants were more likely to
report seeing them and when they weren't
shown the lines some still reported
seeing them suggesting vivid
imaginations at work so taken together
what we can kind of conclude from this
is that when imagination gets really
Vivid it can be mistaken for reality so
the way that we are thinking about this
now is that this is all to do with
sensory strength unlike perky Dyer went
beyond first-person reporting she and
her collaborators analyzed neuroimaging
data from the participants in their
study what they saw suggests that the
visual and prefrontal cortices may be
directly involved in the process of
distinguishing imagination from reality
so I intuitively always thought it was
going to be more like a switch but the
research seems to suggest that it might
be more like a
gradual meter but then the way you're
interpreting this is more binary so like
once it crosses some threshold you're
like oh now it's real and before that
it's not real and that point is what we
call the reality threshold and they're
basically saying that the way that we
distinguish what is seen versus what is
imagined that the strength of this
representation has to exceed a threshold
for us to consider it real or out there
in the world and that's something that
we're really Keen to investigate further
whether we can get measures of this in
individual people and then see if that
relates to things like hallucination
proness or schizophrenia or sometimes in
Parkinson's people experience these
really Vivid hallucinations that are
actually imaginations but they feel real
to these people so one hypothesis would
be that something is wrong in their
reality threshold the more I learn the
more questions I have and the more I
want to keep going
humans are made of nearly 70 trillion
cells but only half of them are truly
ours the other half are foreign microbes
collectively called the human
microbiome covering us inside and out
this intricate ecosystem helps us digest
food and fight off disease even though
the microbiome is an essential part of
who we are it's still largely a mystery
to science researchers have been trying
to better understand how we acquire
these foreign microbes and if they're
exchanged freely between people like
other germs so we say a microbiome but
this means many different species
hundreds to thousands so it's not just
studying one pathogen we have to study
so many microorganisms all of them are
different these organisms vary in terms
of their genomes their functions what
they're doing why they're there how they
interface with the human body and that
presents a lot lot of different
challenges how to grow these organisms
how to study their different and various
functions there's another reason our
microbiome is tricky to study its
inhabitants are constantly changing at
Birth we have an imprinting of the
bacteria from the mother from the
environment and then we
continuously update improve change
modify our uh microbiome during all our
lifetime this year a team of biologists
at the University of trento in Italy
developed new ways to trace gen gentic
strains of microbes as they pass between
individuals so we try to collect as many
samples as possible to get a global
understanding of microbiome Transmission
in the different Lifestyles uh in the
planet we collected more than 9,000
samples for the gut and the or
microbiome so stool and saliva samples
in more than 30 different countries we
just sequence all the DNA that is there
in the sample the challenge here is to
make sense of the sequencing data
considering that we are not looking at
one individual but a community of
individuals all together comparing the
individuals data across familial and
social networks the researchers wanted
to know if microorganisms in the
microbiome could spread from person to
person like a cold or a stomach bug and
what they found suggests that microbes
hop much more extensively than we
thought between people in close physical
proximity like roommates spouses and
children the power of our study was
really that what we saw was
consistent across all these populations
and and and different Lifestyles there
is really a massive transmission of
human microbiome members directly
through social interaction so our social
activity impact our microbiome which in
Impact our biology so the way and the
people we are interacting with is
impacting also our biology our medical
history I think it warrants additional
study into the Dynamics and the sources
and the the full range of sources where
these organisms come from but this is a
huge uh step in understanding the
transmission landscape as humans evolved
our microbiomes may have evolved with us
to protect our health and Immunity but
with the continued use of antibiotics
and antiseptics in the modern world we
may be throwing off our body's natural
microbial balance and leaving ourselves
more susceptible to health risks the
more we study it the more we realize
that the microbiome underlies a lot of
different uh immune Related Disorders in
the body so many of these are chronic
conditions things like cancers
autoimmunity inflammatory bowel disease
and diabetes multiple sclerosis and many
other disorders and so we typically
didn't understand the root causes of
those diseases but as we explore them
more they're not only genetic and
environmental but they have a lot to do
with these organisms that live within
our body we cannot really infer uh
causality so we don't know if the
disease occurs first of the or the
microbiome alterations and so it's very
important to us to understand how we
acquire this bacteria and how we
transmit them to other
individuals this is a human embryo this
is a mouse embryo they both start
growing and building a body in much the
same way but then something strange
happens the human embryo development
slows down and the mouses
accelerates as far as we can tell every
step takes about two to three times
longer in the human embryo than a in the
mouse embryo how and when different
embryonic tissues develop can
dramatically alter an organism's form
but a mystery persists what controls
this difference in
timing new evidence suggests the
mysterious conductor driving development
is an organel scientist may have written
off as a onetick pony so when people
think about mitochondria traditionally
they think about the PowerHouse of the
cell which is producing ATP to provide
energy for cellular functions but
they're also involved in signaling there
is a lot more going on in mitochondria
than just energy production to figure
out the causal relationship between
activity in the mitochondria and the
timing of embryonic development
researchers at Harvard Medical School
manipulated different regions within the
mitochondria of human and mouse stem
cells and in early 2023 they published
their results so we observed that Mouse
cells produce protein faster through the
process of mRNA translation than human
cells and we found that if we
experimentally increase the activity of
mitochondria we could also Force the
cells to produce protein faster and
develop faster this finding was then
echoed by a team of researchers working
in Belgium in a paper they published in
science just Weeks Later which pointed
towards the mitochondria's role in
developmental timing in the nervous
system mitochondria is important in many
aspects just not only the ATP production
and metabolite production and what we
found is mitochondria is working as a
pacemaker of the speed of the
development in cells I think very
important next question is how
mitochondrial activity regulate Gene
regularity Network because Gene
regularity network is also important to
regulate the timing of the development
This research could have major
implications for cell therapy which is
when damaged cells are replaced by
healthy cells and cancer research if we
can find a way by studying developmental
speed to accelerate the production of
cells for therapies then that would be
really important in accelerating the
cell therapy Revolution the tempo is
important to make a different outcome
that's why mitochondria is a important
Pacemaker and make a diversity of the
our animal kingdoms so they have a this
kind of the function as a driving force
of the
[Music]
evolution